[music]
>> So, good morning London.
My name is Edo Salomon. I'm the creator
of Agent Craft. I am also the creator of
MC I and creator and co-maintainer of MC
apps. So, I'm building some of the stuff
that David has been talking about.
As you've all heard in the past day,
agents are amazing.
But if one agent is so amazing, why
don't we scale up to 10 or 20 or 100
different agents and be 100 times more
amazing?
It is pretty simple. We just spin up a
bunch of agents. We put them in this
like nice
screen and it looks really glorious.
But it won't actually work.
And the reason is that
spinning in them up isn't a problem.
It's us. We are the bottleneck in
orchestrating all of these agents.
Now, if you think about it, the role of
the engineer to actually go and manage
dozens of reckless employees is not
typically what we do in most companies.
So,
we need to somehow find these new
potentially new skills
to manage all of these agents.
Luckily,
they're not really brand new. It's not
something that we've never done before.
It's just something that's been hiding
in unexpected places.
I mean, if you're a gamer or used to
play games at any point,
managing dozens of units probably sounds
a little bit familiar.
Which is why I built Agent Craft, which
is an orchestrator that aims to raise
the ceiling of human agent collaboration
by taking learnings from gaming and
transferring them into productivity.
So, let's see a quick walk through of
that and let understand the journey to
raise that ceiling.
So, this is Agent Craft.
There's a lot to unpack. So, we'll just
start with the basics and go from there.
This is an agent.
Not a metaphorical one. This is actually
a physical manifestation of a coding
agent like a live session.
It can be
a you know, cursor. It can be cloud
code, code X, open claw, whatever.
It's something that we can detect on the
device and visualize it, but it's also
something that we can spawn directly
from here.
So, now
we have this agent
and we can prompt it. We can use it like
just any other agent that we have from
our CLI or whatever.
And what can we tell it to do? It has
all of these quirks. You know, we have
voice and we have text and we have
images and so on.
We can just tell it to do stuff. So, for
example, we can tell it to
develop some feature for us.
And
now the agent is working. So, it's doing
its work.
>> [applause]
[applause]
>> So, it's doing work
and as you can see, if you look at the
the the UI, there's like a bunch of
other stuff. We have these buildings and
each building represents some
functionality. So, for example, you
know, one of these buildings manages the
skills and plugins and so on.
There's also, you know, like integrated
terminal and get just to like get that
end-to-end workflow.
The second part of raising the ceiling
that we have the basics is visibility.
We need to be able to quickly understand
what each agent is doing. So, we have
this nice side panel here that really
shows us like high-level mission status
summary and so on. What are they
actually doing?
But the cool thing about Agent Craft is
that we don't just see a list of what
they can do.
We can actually see them working.
So, if we look at the map, you would
notice that it's actually a projection
of my file system.
Each part of my file system is actually
on the map.
So, I have these directories here.
And each one of these directories has
files. These files are represented as
rooms, as you can see here. So, I can
actually track and see visually what the
agent is working on, which file. I can
see the entire change list of what
happened there. And because we're
orchestrating it, I also know which
agents did what and when. So, we can
have full lineage of what's going on.
And we can take this one step further.
If I know all of these stuff, why not
just create a heat map?
I can actually try and see visualize
collisions and I can even prevent them
proactively.
Now,
the cool thing here is that once we have
this visibility, we're not exactly done
yet because we still need to be able to
react to the changes that are happening.
So, we can lean into another cool
mechanism from RTS games. We can simply
use muscle memory to quickly cycle
between the agents that need our help.
They need us to approve the plan. They
need us to
answer some questions and so on.
So, now we have visibility and we can
react quickly. So, we're done. We solved
orchestration.
But not quite because that's really only
the first step. I was able to use more
agents in parallel,
but only for a short amount of time.
There are a few reasons for that. The
first one is that
there's only a limit to how many ideas I
can have in my head at any given time
without being tired. So, what I did is
basically tell the agent to do it. I
told them, "Okay, find missions for me
to do." So, I have quests now and I can
click a button and they just do
whatever. They can refactor test all the
stuff that I don't want to do.
And the second one is that all of this
babysitting takes a lot of time. Like I
need I see what's going on. I can react
to it very quickly, but I still need to
cycle through it.
So,
what I did there is kind of say, "How do
I take myself out of the equation as
much as possible?" So, if agents are so
amazing,
why not just let them do it? I can just
like give them some idea. I have this
campaign feature.
Broadly say what I want to happen and I
would just spin up a container. I would
let the agents run there. They can
decompose the task. They can plan it.
They can present the plan to me. I don't
care what they're doing because it's
container, so do whatever.
And the main thing here is that once
it's decomposed, I'm not the one doing
the babysitting. Now, I have the
campaign orchestrator and that's his
problem.
So, we're actually moving more of the
effort only to the planning phase or the
review phase.
And
once we have that,
we reach a point where we can just say,
"Why is it my ideas? Why can't I tell it
to have like run in a cron job, go to
Twitter every day, scan cool ideas and
just implement them?" I just decide what
I want. Which is actually how I
implemented channels pretty quickly.
So, we have that and now I just have a
lot of different PRs to review. So,
there's this
nice capability of just review bundles.
And now I can see exactly what changes
happened in each one. Like why did they
do stuff? What are the tasks? And I also
have visual evidence.
So, now I am able to just look at
screenshots. I can look at videos and
really see what's going on without
investing too much time in doing it.
And
once we have that, we can actually shift
more of the work from the planning to
the review.
How much time do I need to spend on the
plan if I can just
do it 10 times and I'll just pick the
one that is most fitting for me.
And the next part is
we're still not done. I mean, if you
think about it, this is only the first
step because agents aren't that smart
yet. So, we need to offload it to
someone else. Humans.
Now, what I can do, and this is my
favorite feature, is that we can
actually create these workspaces. So, I
can collaborate with the product
designer from my team and they can do
whatever they want and we can I can just
continue from where they left off.
So, for example, let's say this is an
agent actually from the product designer
on their computer. So, they can see my
agents. I can see their agents. I can
understand what they're doing and we can
just collaborate.
Um
Yeah, they just started working again.
So, I can see that they want to design
this new page, which is pretty cool.
So, I can wait for them to finish or I
can just go ahead now and just hand off
from them to my agents.
Well, our agents.
Insert communist,
whatever.
So, we have our agents now and I can
just keep going from there. And the cool
thing is that it's not just
human-to-human collaboration.
We are also collaborating with the
agents. So, there's more direct stuff
like this. I can just type stuff and
prompt my agents or even their agents.
But there's also a softer mechanism.
There's actually a chat that is
between humans and humans, but also
between the humans and the agents. You
can see here that the agent said, "I'm
starting to work on something." And then
I can say, "I'm also working on it." So,
the next time the agent does something,
it knows someone else is working. They
can also have soft collaboration, so
they would know what files each one is
changing.
So, we've actually taken a bunch of
stuff that were
limiting us from really reaching our
full potential with agents and kind of
solve them one by one. There are a bunch
of other features that I just didn't
have time to go over,
but you can try them out and see for
yourself if you can really work better
that way.
So, to sum up, uh
these are not exactly new skills. I
mean, you're probably worried perhaps
that you won't be able to get adapted to
this future where we're not actually
coding, we're just telling other people
to code for us or other agents.
Uh but these skills are there. They're
just not something we used for work
until now. Uh so with games as one
example, we can take these skills to the
next level.
We need to somehow raise that ceiling.
We need to somehow improve our
collaboration with agents. Uh and with
Agent Craft, the goal is to take the
learnings from games and really raise
that to the next level with better
visibility, uh more autonomy to the
agents, and human-to-agent
collaboration.
So, I invite you to go to uh the
website. Uh this is the QR code. You can
It's free. You can just download it and
play with it. Uh it's still
experimental. It's still new. There's a
bunch of stuff that need to change, uh
but it will only happen with great
feedback. There's also Discord.
Uh so, please join. Give us uh your
feedback, and
let's raise the ceiling together.
Thank you.
>> [applause]
[music]